you've done a couple of game shows
lately I've noticed and seem to enjoy
them you did was it to tell the truth
yeah I with a legend yeah I they I they
asked if I would be on to tell the truth
and they said Mel Brooks was gonna be
unbelievable I would do that naked and
afraid show with him if he I would go I
would just to meet him I don't do that
yeah well he's and I couldn't believe he
was there and I cuz Blazing Saddles
Young Frankenstein and he did I anxiety
Godfather yep and avatar yeah he and I
could I was so excited to meet him and
he was as funny he's 91 and he has more
energy than a box of puppies and he's so
exciting and he and then he had this
very quiet moment that he answered and
Anderson hosts to tell the truth and it
was it was the cameras were on he's like
Anthony can I just say something and
everyone listens cuz it's Mel Brooks and
he goes I'm so happy all my friends are
dead because they will never see this
[Laughter]
this true you also did you did yeah I
got scheme with Alec Baldwin right doing
all the game shows yeah well you don't
have a show you just do gay it's great
no and again this Alec Baldwin hosting
the classic match game I don't know if
you guys watch that from the 70s gene
Rayburn but it I didn't I know how much
they want to ply you with alcohol during
the show he told me this I do know I did
it once and it was like it 9 o'clock in
the morning and they're so yours like
seriously have a drink like oh no it's
alright music no have a drink great let
me marry take it easy you know but the
probably you I let go quickly you cave
alright alright Mary but no it's it's
it's weird and you look at the 70s
version and they were smoking and
they're they're wasted and so next time
I'm gonna take heroin or cocaine
do a speedball right before I do yeah
my god that's the new era would you ever
go on one of those game shows I don't
know I would I just always think that I
would I wouldn't be a I knew the answer
I wouldn't come up with it in that
moment I always think I just I don't
have that quick you don't have a quick
brain no no I have a brain I know things
but I would I don't know that's a
microbiologist you've mentioned that but
I mention that on every show yes no no
you should be called Late Night with
Conan whose dad is a microbiome like but
I feel like you would obviously you
don't need to ever go on a show like
that like I know that I've vested very
poorly yeah I I'll be on a show I I
could do it sure yeah
all right so then this is a promise yeah
okay yeah well it's real dis crowd look
it's better this crowds gonna do a game
Tony's gonna do a game show
you